- Hi. My name is Elizabeth,
and I help create the SAT.
In this video, I'm going to
tell you about the section
of the new SAT called the Reading Test.
We'll go over what it
tests, how it's scored,
and what you can expect to see on it.
The new SAT is made up
of two main sections,
math and evidence-based
reading and writing.
And the evidence-based
reading and writing section
is made out of two tests,
reading, and writing and language.
So let's learn more
about the reading test.
The reading test is designed
to measure how ready you are
to read and interpret the kinds of texts
you're likely to encounter in
college and in your career.
The reading test is scored
on a scale of 10 to 40.
Your score on the reading test
and your score on the writing
and language test combine
to give you your evidence-based
reading and writing score,
which is on a scale of 200 to 800.
When you get your SAT scores,
you'll also see some subscores.
Along with some of the questions
on the writing and language test,
some questions on the reading test
will ask you to interpret
the meanings of words
based on the context of the passages
in which they appear.
These questions contribute
to your words and context subscore.
Other questions on the
reading test, again,
along with some of the questions
on the writing and language test,
will ask you to interpret,
synthesize, and use evidence
found in a wide range of sources,
including graphics and a variety of texts.
These questions will contribute
to your command of evidence subscore.
Both of these subscores
are on a scale of 1 to 15.
In addition to subscores, you'll also see
some cross-test scores.
These scores will be reported
on a scale of 10 to 40
and will be based on selected questions
from the reading, writing
and language, and math tests
that reflect the application
of reading, writing,
language, and math skills in history,
social studies, and science contexts.
All of these scores
help to build a better,
more detailed picture of your
college and career readiness.
Okay, now back to the reading
text and what it looks like.
All of the questions on the reading test
are linked to a passage,
a pair of passages,
or a passage with an
informational graphic or graphics.
Think of tables, charts, and graphs.
The reading test has five
passages that vary in length
from 500 to 750 words each.
Every passage or pair
of passages has 10 or 11
questions with it for a
total of 52 questions.
You'll have 65 minutes
to read the passages
and answer the questions.
On each test, you can expect to see
at least one pair of passages
and at least one passage
with an informational graphic or graphics.
For example, here's a single
social science passage
followed by a bar graph.
Let's take a minute to talk about
the different types of passages.
In the reading test, you're going to see
both literary and informational passages.
Literary passages will be
drawn from works of fiction,
usually an excerpt from
a short story or novel
from the U.S. or other parts of the world.
The informational passages will be drawn
from published non-fiction works
in the area of history,
social studies, and science.
You can expect to see at
least one science passage,
at least one social science passage,
and at least one passage
from the founding documents
along the lines of the
Declaration of Independence
or the Constitution or from
the great global conversations
such works inspire.
The purposes of the passages will vary.
The purpose might be to tell a story,
make an argument, explain a
study or experiment, and so on.
The passages will also
cover a range of complexity,
from texts written at a 9th grade level
up to what you would expect
to see early in college
or other post-secondary training.
Now let's talk about
the types of questions
that are on the reading test.
Generally, the questions fall
into three main categories.
You'll see questions about
the information and ideas
in the passage.
That is, what the passage says directly
or what it implies.
You'll also see questions that ask about
the rhetoric in the passage.
Think about structure, purpose,
and the craft of writing.
These questions ask how the author
of the passage says something.
And you'll see questions
that ask you to synthesize
information by asking
you to draw connections
between two related passages
or between a passage and
an informational graphic or graphics.
If you'd like to know more about
the reading test questions,
you'll be able to see videos
that give an in-depth look
at the different question types,
how they work, and what they look like.
So that's the introduction
to the reading test.
Now try reading a few passages
and answering some practice questions
to get familiar with the SAT.